[Music]
[Laughter]
any type of father or mother is my
oldest son
[Laughter]
it's timeout
most people are submitted by trollface
ooh
most people's partners are probably
lying to them about the memes they send
what do you mean most people's partners
most people's partners sorry probably
lying about them to me about the memes
that they send yes why what is it I
don't even Sam mean means what does that
mean about me what it means about me
what the [ __ ] does that mean I sent you
a meme just kidding I did it you don't
send me memes I'll send you memes so
just for the people that then means
through each other's none of you can
relate apparently so I'm taught once and
a great way it's got to be a really good
move what that mean was supposed to mean
when you said Oh
what we're talking about here is for
those couples that you only mean as a
love language so they'll be like oh this
is hilarious like did you see this and
like oh they'll say oh yeah that was
great
no no so then I don't get it I tell you
every once and almost send each other
memes okay I wanna [ __ ] hear a much
better understand Oh me I gotta do is
just stay quiet we'll get it okay okay
okay okay
so for these couples SM use to each
other this is for those people that are
like oh man I already saw it but then
the other person kind of gets hurt if
you didn't laugh at it but that's why on
Sun means to Jess she already bought way
before me okay other people so let's say
for you and Jess right so you find a
meme that you really like and you want
to share with just because for you
sharing a meme is kind of like your
lovely would you want to share with if I
shared it with her if she already told
me or I saw it and then it does happen
to know enough I'm like man you're on
the internet wait long wait wait mother
that I am they will take that so within
your position they would take that as
like damn well if you saw that and you
like you couldn't think of me to send it
to me because you thought it was funny
and like you wouldn't want to obviously
get butthurt about it
some people do that's a huge [ __ ]
loser from both sides too cuz like the
person who has seen all the memes they
kind of feel bad and so they they end up
being in this predicament of like should
I so they go haha when they don't really
mean it
they're going along and you're like roll
a little guy rolling on the floor or
trol oh it's like laughter with the
troll you know the troll a little guy
yeah yeah do you guys don't get it you
guys all know that's not online they're
not like people
we're not
while these pension is back with an axe
he said this is disproved right now
that's how I feel too when people are
talking about gaming and [ __ ] like they
don't game pointless to its play ok ok
so then that person is left feeling like
damn should I lie and be like uh Anna it
was really funny or should I be honest
and be like Oh always be honest what the
[ __ ] no no but then being honest then
your partner ends up being like oh you
guys you know what's is such a funny
[ __ ]
no problem this actually happened to me
the other day with my lovely lady did
you cry no because this this is this is
what happens so she sent me something
right and it was like this black and
gray photo of this of this white dude
and this white girl kissing each other
so stock image from Target it was like a
post I looked at it I looked at it I
went this must not be for me did you see
it as I see what and she goes the thing
I said you today I was like oh I thought
you might want to send that somebody
else cuz what's it have to do with me
you're [ __ ] open it and I read it I
was like I don't get it actually mean
and so the the the the post was that
this girl it wrote a post about her
boyfriend with a picture of them kissing
each other because he put up a chicken
wire fence for her that she asked him to
do and so in return she gave him his
love language back which is affection
and so she put that post up she's
sending you subliminals box and she said
that to me and I was like ok so are you
saying that I don't do that for you
because now bait me pissed off or are
you saying I am this boyfriend I'm a
good boyfriend and she goes I've seen
you're a good boyfriend I was like oh so
her love language was him installing
chicken wire fence she asked him to do
yeah so like I told so we had a
conversation after that where she was
like so you don't read the stuff that I
send you I was like okay here's here's
the thing it's not that I wouldn't read
it it's just that when I read it
I never give you the reaction that you
want it's like when we go to Disneyland
I don't go oh yes sir I don't do that
for you so like what I'm saying is when
you send those things
send that to other people so it's like
you're soaked
identify the dish right that you just
finished cooking and you know that it's
pom and you want the shared reaction of
like yeah that's really good I don't
believe it to it get the reaction that
he wants you'll send it to me maybe yeah
yeah Oh or someone else that eats but
you wouldn't care that like so because
so for me the way I see it is just like
as a respect right like if she respects
you and you respect her then because you
know it's important to her then you
would just that's cuz you grew up with
manners yeah people that grew up with a
lot of like politics I did dude this is
a good one though I call it politics
because like my family was like that so
then it's like it just depends on how
you're raised cuz you know like your mom
you said your mom's super blunt right so
she could be crass oh this tastes like
[ __ ] whatever it's fine cuz in that
family it's fine yeah it's rude to a
family that didn't that wasn't raised
that way
yes comedy it's like you're not yeah cuz
my mom is very very straightforward you
know and so for me what I was telling
her it was just that no matter what
reaction I give you it's not gonna be
honest and real so for me I'll enjoy it
but I'm not gonna enjoy to the extent
that you want so just don't send me
those things cuz you're always gonna get
disappointed so if I make this dish
right that's fair and she eats it she
goes it's good I understand that's her
version of that's awesome yes I give it
to Bart and Bart's my god oh my god
[ __ ] up is when you go this is some
good ass burrito
what did you do to this burrito and
she's gonna think this is something that
you love that you that you're gonna make
all the time now you know you're forced
to [ __ ] eat that real [ __ ] dad's
butt that farts guys red bean soup all
[ __ ] hot positive thank you
and I was like this is awesome dude from
that point on I got it every day he got
mad that I didn't eat it every day
I was like oh that's what I'm scared of
because I'm scared that if I give it to
her once she's gonna send that [ __ ] to
me all the time and then it's gonna just
be more apparent that I'm not gonna like
so just be honest with her yeah so in
this article I do mention some research
from dr. John Gottman have you guys ever
heard oh yeah no because he's really big
and actually entire relationships and
like the therapy and all that so cool
he's like a marital guru yeah and his
wife they did a lot of studying and like
newlyweds are like just marry people
whatever the point is here that they
mentioned these things called emotional
bid and so it's when your partner it's
like little moments that your partner
buys for your attention right and so
they're asking it and doing pretty much
they're pretty much asking like if you
saw a certain like white with this whole
main thing it's kind of like this is an
emotional bit of like I'm trying to
connect with you I'm trying to know I
want you to turn towards me don't turn
away from me in this moment of me trying
to connect with you here's a better
analogy alright I'm a [ __ ] bear okay
and you try to bait me with a bowl of
lettuce you should have brought salmon
[ __ ] and it would have been way
different but it's not about you it's
about the other person opening up and
sharing their interests so they're the
ones that like that but you share the
lettuce to the bear that doesn't give a
[ __ ] about know I think there's layers
to it though it's like first of all like
are the partners really open about their
communication and they like really
understand each other because then
within that context you should have an
idea of like what you would find what
they would find entertaining if they
really wouldn't but then there is also
like because this person's my partner
I can definitely rather than shut them
down go at least half way at least try
to meet them halfway doesn't work with
her though I know this oh well then
that's yeah that I went to Disneyland
with a [ __ ] fever and it wasn't
enough for her cuz I wasn't having a
good enough time okay as it was raining
you should have went on cocaine it
wasn't so much that you weren't having a
blast maybe you looked pissed yeah I
think you were Forrest no I wasn't I
actually had a
time and I told it after we were in the
car I was like oh that was a pretty good
time and she goes like that's the
hardest hold on a second do you mean she
well she goes why I'm glad you had a
good time and I'm like what's going on
here yeah yeah you didn't have a good
time she goes no it's just like usually
when I go with my friends we're like
super excited
we're like having a great so you're not
giving her the emotional energy that she
wants from you normally would get from
Disney fanatics which is the norm but
also she's not knowing understanding
kids yes of course you're not gonna have
the energy so I told her like if I
brought you to a UFC fight right and
blood splatters on your face and you go
I would be so [ __ ] pissed
you better be like I want to see that
[ __ ] but I think that's why
communication is so important because
it's like I think in that situation it's
kind of unfair for her to expect you to
get as excited like it's okay for you to
be like okay you know what
I love this girl and I know this is what
she enjoys and even though I might not
enjoy it because I mean you know you're
you're you're right you're a hundred
percent you're right
but you're forgetting that there's
baggage and relationships so by the time
this happens people are blowing up for
stupid reasons because of some [ __ ] that
happened ten times already or twenty
times or a hundred times yes see like
for me though when I'm when I'm in a
relationship I oh I cause I hate
passive-aggressive [ __ ] I can't handle
that
so like I'm very very open and honest
about communication very direct I'm like
this so open and honest can get you into
a lot of fights - it can yeah bye
I feel like kind of where then you kind
of hope like both people are mature
enough to like really talk about it oh
you have been there then problem terney
don't mean [ __ ]
maturity here's [ __ ] baggage it's
like this to like you also have to take
into consideration that people have
personal baggage from their upbringing
that they're going to project on you
yeah yeah so like there's times we're
like irrationally I get in trouble be
because it triggers a memory of
something else from their childhood or
whatever and I'm the bad guy
right and then I don't realize that so I
feed into the anger I fight back yeah
and vice versa
it could be a meme or whatever like in
this situation but that's just the
that's just code for hey I need
attention you're not giving it to me the
way I want it same with your Disneyland
thing it's all it's all sacrifice given
taste me is so close to her [ __ ]
heart dude yeah if there wasn't that
important to it wouldn't be that big of
a deal but I try I'm Mickey Mouse
sweater dude with your shitty crumbly
face my face was not grumpy it was like
this but the funny part is how much you
resist [ __ ] hurt to just [ __ ] around
and play no it's just with the fever
with the fever it's very hard to [ __ ]
around I never memory tell me that
that's like your 12th time going yes so
the first like three four times that
went it was really fun
but now that match is gone for me cuz
it's not important to me so she never
complained about the energy in them so
she you mentioned the first years well
the first few times we went yes the
first eighteen times I went it was fun
yeah y'all go that off yeah we went a
lot Wow cuz she works for dis all right
you did your duty man yeah it wasn't
like you're a dick face the first day so
this is what it's like the first time I
went
Tinkerbell came down said hello hello
David how are you second time oh it's
you again David third time fourth time
Tinkerbell is just cracked out she has
[ __ ] red eyes it's like a swords
buttered face you smoking a cigarette
and she sees you and she goes
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]